une journée ludique pour sensibiliser au
développement durable c'est l'expérience
vécue par ces 320 collégiens echo
délégués yvelinois au domaine de Madame
Elisabeth à Versailles depuis la rentrée
2020 chaque classe des établissements
secondaires doit posséder un de ses
ambassadeurs son rôle formé ses
camarades aux éco-gestes et porter des
initiatives environnementales ce qu'on
fait c'est que du coup on fait des
réunions et on essaye de
préparer des projets pour l'avenir pour
éviter un max
ne gaspillage ou polluer par les gestes
du quotidien par l'évolution de ces
modes de consommation il faut se
préparer à lutter contre ce
réchauffement contre ce dérèglement
climatique et parce qu'il entraîne en
fait un risque immense pour l'humanité
puis sur l'environnement atelier sur le
tri sélectif ou encore l'impact du
textile sur la planète ce vendredi 12
mai une trentaine de stands était
présent pour permettre aux échodés les
gays de développer leur connaissance ça
c'est pour économiser le papier c'est
bien mais là si on essaye d'économiser
l'énergie qu'on a créé un jeu
sur la consommation électrique des
appareils donc les élèves doivent
classer c'est comme un jeu time line
doivent classer de les appareils d'entre
ceux qui se consomme le moins à ceux qui
consomment le plus on a appris qu'il y a
les anciennes ampoules qui chauffaient
beaucoup et que c'est mieux d'utiliser
des LED moi c'est consommatrice lors de
cette première journée organisée par le
Département 4 collèges ont été
récompensés pour soutenir les projets
des écoles délégués 1000 euros et le don
d'un arbre ont été remis aux
établissements
[Applaudissements]